it's complicated but it's also as simple
as taking the genetically encoded sensor
and embedding it in the embryo of the
fruit fly uh-huh and then having that
embryo divide and divide and divide and
divide and make the fruit fly thousands
of the fruit fly no because they
multiply really fast after you have one
yeah like that breeds because the fruit
fly you will make new babies and all the
new babies
carried our new sensors they carry the
sensors yes Wow and so then after just a
couple months see you have thousands of
flies with our third two sensors okay
and then the fly has to you know be that
that safe glue has to be used to keep it
on the on the foil or the paper so thank
you I think you must talk with some fly
person previously do you do long
mentioned it on the show oh you have to
have a safe non-harmful glue yes to keep
the fruit fly on the record chamber the
image in the imaging chamber yet you
mount the flies and we use wishes
Twitter's to open a very small window on
the fly's head and expels the brain but
in not touch and you know her the brand
keep the brain intact and let the fly
think everything it won't you think yes
really
so you can use very small tweezers to
open the fruit fries brain just a little
bit and not not just a little bit wait a
bit but my eyes I did not touch I do not
touch the bread I do I open up the
cuticle or your skin of the
of the head and expose the brain so that
the two-photon microscopy can go past
the skin yes more easily to the brain
yeah and then the but man is brought up
yes and then you were looking at the
two-photon microscopy and then you see
the as the fruit fly smells the tiny
little pieces of banana and you see the
fluorescence of about a hundred or so of
your yeah let some light lights up of
the neurons yes that have the dopamine
sensors yes attached to them that yes
yes genetically encoded these sensors
from the embryo until that's how this is
this is an excellent scientific
advancement that has so much potential
thank you yeah